this rail bridge is the only border
crossing between Russia and North Korea
in early November satellite imagery
showed a train crossing into Russia the
first movement observed there in years
in the past the railway was used to
transport passengers and goods but
Russia and North Korea didn't return our
questions on what the train was carrying
this time it is one sign of renewed
activity between the two countries which
have indicated a desire to expand their
partnership their leaders have exchanged
letters Russia said it recently sent
thoroughbred horses to North Korea and
Pyongyang is even looking to help
rebuild parts of Ukraine
but U.S intelligence says the
cooperation is deeper
and that Pyongyang is selling arms to
Moscow this would go against United
Nations sanctions and both countries
denied the reports so here's what we
know about how the two isolated nations
are growing closer
Putin and Kim haven't officially met
since 2019 but they've exchanged at
least six letters this year both leaders
have regularly mentioned the corporation
between the two countries that's never
been stronger
Pyongyang has been the only Capital to
recognize moscow's sham referendums that
paved the way for the Kremlin to claim
occupied Ukrainian regions as part of
the Russian Federation
on its end Russia has blocked
washington-led efforts to enforce
additional sanctions on North Korea
after a recent barrage of missile
launches
North Korea is also looking to help
Moscow on the ground in Ukraine
in July North Korea's ambassador to
Russia met with an official from the
Russian occupied Donetsk Republic
discussing joint projects in
construction Agriculture and other
sectors
there is no evidence that North Koreans
are working in the occupied territories
which would violate the U.N ban on the
use of North Korean labor Russian
officials said they looked into how to
employ North Korean workers without
breaching un resolutions
those International sanctions also
affect Goods including arms sales the
dprk is covertly supplying Russia with a
significant number of artillery shells
the Democratic People's Republic of
Korea or dprk is being accused by the US
of using a network of countries in the
Middle East and North Africa to send
ammunition to Russian forces
Pyongyang is a major producer of arms
holding large stockpiles much of it is
based on Soviet era technology and is
very similar to Russian weapons all this
North Korea Watchers say makes it an
attractive source of ammunition for
Russia although trade of the two
countries is heavily restricted by a
slew of sanctions some Western officials
have assessed that Russia is running
through its Arsenal as military experts
estimate it fires approximately 20 000
shells per day
as Russia grows more isolated it's
looking for any help it can get the
resumption of the train traffic with
North Korea suspended during the
pandemic shows how Moscow is looking to
work with its eastern neighbor and
experts on North Korea and Russia agree
that the two countries will only grow
closer as Russia seeks support for its
War
and North Korea which has been
particularly isolated in recent years
could also benefit from a stronger
Alliance of Moscow both politically and
economically